this is us star justin hartley and
sophia pernice are married
a source tells et on monday that the two
officially tied the knot saying quote
justin and sophia have only been married
for a short period of time and their
ceremony was private
the couple had an instant chemistry and
early on discussed marriage
rumors that the couple said i do heat it
up over the weekend when eagle-eyed fans
noticed that the newlyweds were sporting
what appeared to be
matching wedding rings at the 2021 mtv
movie and tv
awards in los angeles the outing marked
their first red carpet together as a
couple
the news comes four months after the
actor finalized his divorce from krishel
staus we met through sort of like a
series of friends
me inquiring about her at a certain
point and then her kind of inquiring
about me at a certain point and then us
putting the pieces together and
realizing that we were inquiring about
each other
justin filed for divorce from the
dancing with the stars alum in november
2019
after two years of marriage best thing
about being married so far
oh gosh i like just saying wife you just
like saying well i like
alex i know we've been doing that a lot
like hey husband
the surprise split unfolded on
christelle's netflix show selling sunset
it's just a lot all at once because
everybody in the whole world knows
i love him so much this was my best
friend who do i talk to now
it's not the ideal situation to be put
in to have cameras around you at that
time
it was um not something that i would
have chosen
obviously but hopefully the viewers will
follow us along the journey and
be kind and once justin and chriselle's
divorce was finalized the source adds it
made the next step of marrying sophia
more of a reality the couple began
dating last may with the two making
their relationship
instagram official on new year's eve
last july et
spoke to justin where he admitted he's a
happy guy
i think i'm i sleep like a baby i don't
have anything on my mind
i really i treat people the way i want
to be treated and i um
i have lovely friends who love me and i
love them and i've got this wonderful
daughter and i've got a great family and
i'm i am a very uh very lucky
lucky individual